rahoui zarour leur tour s'il vous plaît
de l'émission souplesse que ce soit dans
leur auto parce que on me dit qu'il se
passe un truc souplet leur tour adrian
reste que c'est adrien je vais rien qu
au riksdag est le même être le maître
mais je rigole bien le malawi alors il
ya une personne croyant voilà alors est
est ce que leur nom mais là les mecs ça
j'aimerais qu'ils veulent à côté de moi
moi ça me va bien sa belle isabelle au
peuple de dire ça mais elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa balle en plus ça fait plaisir de tout
d'abord trouvé voilà une fonction à
maxime guény ressemble à un maxi cabas
écouter en plus beau ah bon ça va
alors là parce que le langage langage
des signes
parce que vous allez les traduire les
missions voilà en langage des signes
mais moi j'ai un langage particulier
comment on fait pour dire par exemple
d'art caron langage des signes
alors d'arca faut prendre le sens donc
de savoir ce que ça veut dire c'est à
dire que c'est le rigolade oui en
chaleureuse accord est très bien qu'on
peut faire ambiance ouais chaleureuse
par exemple d'accord on beranger
d'accord très bien chiron comment on
peut dire voilà par exemple si je dis
pendant qu'au mondial hanouna en langue
des signes
alors il ya des signes qu'on peut donner
à des personnalités inconnues ou youri
vous n'avez pas encore de signaux façon
c'est ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut trouver une caractéristique
propre aveu la dernière fois j'ai vu
parce qu'il parlait de moi dans un truc
mais faisait ça parce que j'ai les
oreilles décollées et donc une ampoule
pour ça comment fait donald trump comme
ça c'est presque ça dans ses rêves j'en
étais sûr c'est ça emmanuel macron un
manuel macron servir d enfin ouais c'est
vrai les pâtes les prêts à comme ça donc
on fait comme ça emmanuel macron kim
kardashian mario sessa formation fait
quand kim kardashian va je crois pas
qu'il y ait de signes officiels mais à
mon avis oui ça il y aura un lien avec
le postérieur je m'en excuse
et est ce que les frères bogdanoff ont
fait ça alors c'est pareil je crois pas
qu'il ait de signes officiels mais ça
pourrait être les pommettes le menton
comme ils sont frères enfin largement
ton combiné je sais par l accord peut
faire comme ça votre combiné merci
d'être là et génial on vous êtes un
amour parce que pourquoi vous avez
appris le langage des signes
j'ai appris la langue des signes parce
que j'aime les langues en général est
que ces noms qui m'intéressait que
j'aime discuter avec le maximum de gens
possible donc c'est incroyable on bat
bravo et merci ça je n'en sais rien
bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]